let's feature the Health Minister Edward
agro hello Shi mr. ogre thanks for
joining us and we are looking at
potentially other sites like that as
well up and down the country where are
they well at the moment we are focused
on getting the Excel center turned into
NHS Nightingale Hospital that's our key
priority at the moment working very
closely with our ma D and Army
colleagues 4,000 beds there eventually
500 on stream next week we are of course
going to look at how that works and to
make sure that around the country we can
ensure there is sufficient additional
capacity where it's needed but I focus
at the moment is getting that first one
up and running altruistic Brits
something about half a million even more
signed up what would you like to say to
them and do you still need more well the
first thing I won't say is what the
prime minister said yesterday K which is
a huge thank you when he spoke it was
four hundred and five thousand people
who signed up against the target of
250,000 this morning as you say it's
past the half a million mark more always
welcome this is a huge national effort
everyone is welcome I'd encourage
everyone to get involved but as I say
for me from the prime minister it's a
huge thank you I think this is a country
at its best are you about a significant
percentage of the population who aren't
key workers moving around during a
lockdown which is basically what's going
to happen well you've seen very clearly
what the prime minister said what the
chief medical officer said stay at home
protect our NHS and save lives and that
stay at home message is hugely important
when the PM set out at the beginning of
this week why he was ramping up those
those restrictions ramping up what we
were asking people to do to save lives
he set out the very very narrow set of
criteria and narrow set of reasons as to
why people should still be doing
something outside of their own house but
he was very clear apart from that narrow
set of exceptions people really do need
to stay home we heard there from that
the gentlemen there who've been working
on the Excel site saying only now is he
he and others realise just how
significant this is and he was saying
we've all got to do our bit there he's
absolutely right
the message of stay home is so important
okay so how did these half-a-million
volunteers to fit into that criteria
well what what those criteria say is
among others among the four is the one
that says if you are helping other
people helping vulnerable people by
collecting medicines getting food to
them that is a legitimate reason not to
be at home but to be fulfilling that
role but the chief medical officer was
also very clear that when doing that and
it's a hugely important role people
should still follow the guidance about
keeping two meters away non-contact
drop-off of deliveries etc it's all
there on the website right very
important encouraging people to sign up
for it encouraging people to do it
recognizing that is one of those roles
where people do have a legitimate reason
to be out of the house but to make sure
they follow that guidance lots to get
through explain to me the justification
for the Prince of Wales receiving your
test while frontline workers haven't had
one well I'm not going to comment on the
Prince of Wales medical care or his
particular position because that's an
individual case and I'm not going to
comment because care I'm not going to
comment on any one individual case but
hang on hang on let me let me ask you a
question though your question is this
why has the Prince of Wales received a
test while frontline workers who are
saving our lives the lives of our loved
ones are unable to and what I said Kay
is let me answer your question which is
what I was going to do my understanding
is that his symptoms his condition met
that criteria however let me talk about
those frontline workers which is exactly
what your right to focus on because
today we are announcing the free parking
in NHS hospitals that sector of state
said to all trust many are doing this
already giving them free parking we're
saying to everyone give your staff free
parking because that's about supporting
our staff not testing is another key
element of supporting frontline staff
and it's not just I should say it's not
just about NHS workers it's about social
care workers it's about those
pharmacists it's about hospice workers
so does that broader family of people
who are working to save lives we've
already done over 97 thousand tests at
the moment that's one of the highest
figures around the world but there is
clearly more to do and that's why we've
said we are ramping up that effort on
testing started off with 5000 secretary
of states being clear 5,000 to 10,000 to
25,000 a day we are ramping up the
capacity to do those tests as fast as we
can and of course key workers frontline
NHS and social care workers a front of
the queue for that but also we've got to
remember the testing protocol which also
says that those who are in hospital who
are the most seriously ill are being
tested as well because we need to know
whether they're infectious to help those
frontline staff know how to treat those
people so we are doing it we are ramping
it up you're absolutely right to
highlight it and that's why we're
putting so much effort into ramping up
those so you acknowledge there are lots
of people that fulfil the criteria so
why did the Prince of Wales jump the
queue the Prince of Wales didn't jump
the queue we are focused on making sure
that we ramp up those tests around the
country for our frontline workers there
is a significant national effort
underway to do that we are ramping it up
dramatically every day but as I say I've
answered that question but I'm not going
to go into any further details about his
Royal Highness save that I'm sure
everyone would wish him and anyone else
with this virus well I'm sure my viewers
will make their own mind up on the
answers that we're getting this morning
talk to me about how we are protecting
Brits from the rest of the world Spain
has the second highest number of kovat
19 deaths after Italy we had a look this
morning the team we are two metres
separated you can still fly from the
from Spain from Madrid in fact into the
UK this morning in fact three flights
arriving from Madrid into London today
that's the worst affected region in
Spain how can that be right but we've
got the clear criteria if people come
back we want we've said to Brits abroad
come home if you can we know that many
of them are facing challenges with that
with Airlines but if you are abroad come
home there are clear guidance on the
website as to what you should do if you
are coming from particular infected
if you're coming back and have symptoms
and how you should behave but we do
think it's important as the foreign
sector have said that Brits abroad
should come home if they are able to do
so but to follow those guidelines follow
the medical advice when they get back to
this country about staying at home and
and if they have symptoms the periods of
isolation at home that they should
follow tell me what tests are in place
when they arrive back at Heathrow or
wherever else in terms of temperatures
that we'd the UK and based on the
scientific advice we've been given those
tests are not the best way to do this
when people come back people should
follow the guidance they get the
announcements on the plane they get the
leaflets and the advice on what they
should do when they come back but a
temperature test or similar as we saw
earlier on in this pandemic isn't
particularly effective firstly there can
be other reasons why someone can have a
temperature secondly in some cases a
temperature test won't show up someone
who has got the virus so we've got to be
realistic I can understand why people
might want to see those sort of tests at
the border at airports but we also got
to follow the medical advice okay which
says that they are not always the best
way of telling whether someone actually
does or doesn't have the disease
following the medical advice about
symptoms is the key thing okay so we
only have time for one more question I
know you're very busy you know we have
temperature checks that every one of our
sky buildings we employ one as I came in
we old yep we all have our temperature
checks taken that is a medical advice
that we have been given just to clarify
people can get a flight today from the
centre of Madrid to the United Kingdom
that is the center of the Cova deaths in
Madrid in Spain and they can get off a
flight in the United Kingdom and travel
home and we as a country are doing
nothing about that why are you seeing a
in Spain those who have symptoms there
is a quarantine there and people who
have symptoms should be seeking medical
help there and should be following the
local rules but you're right if someone
doesn't have symptoms and someone is
able symptom-free to get themselves back
to the UK we've said they should do so
but they should follow the medical of
if they develop symptoms when they get
to the UK or indeed on the flight okay
finally self-employed are going to get
good news today well I'm not going to
print what the Chancellor is going to
say but I know and we've heard on your
program on other news outlets from
self-employed people who understandably
are deeply concerned about their
livelihoods and their ability to pay the
bills these people are the bedrock of
our economy we've put together a huge
package of support for individuals and
for businesses but quite rightly we need
to make sure we look after the
self-employed it's not been easy as the
prime minister said because of the
nature of self-employment it's a complex
thing to do but I know that the
Chancellor has been working with his
team incredibly hard he knows we need to
and he wishes to support the
self-employed and you'll see a further
announcement on that later today from
the Chancellor Minister I hope that you
and your family keep well and keep safe
thank you very much
likewise to UK thank you